what do you think about this uh kaison
that jail stream have you seen clips
from it so I've never watched like a
stream live but I I don't I'm probably
like most people I've watched tons of
clips from it like it's amazing like God
Bless the people that are clipping out
these streams cuz they have to watch it
yeah and they have to watch it and edit
it down to the fun [__] for us to enjoy
yeah and um I think Kai's been really
transformative with the streaming where
he like creates games out of it mhm and
like I've seen certain people travel and
certain people do these things and then
everybody kind of repeats the same thing
you know it's like I'm going to go to
Japan it's like okay well now I'll go to
Japan and then everybody goes to Japan
and then blah blah blah and it's like no
real nothing really unique but like at
least this scenario he's creating is
truly unique within the streaming space
he's creating a game out of it yes and
uh this gu great man he's reaping the
rewards it's it's a really smart way of
going about content but free Kai man
hold your head bro you hold it down bro
so what's the deal is this a set or did
they rent out an old jail I think they
got an old prison that's it it looks
like an old prison or they got a movie
set that was used like you know what I
mean like I'm sure La has a prison set
yeah that is built in the exact same you
know structures or whatever like a
prison to shoot all their shows like
where did where was Oz shot yeah you
know where was sha shank shot all
probably there but um it's great and
then in and like injecting all of the
different famous people as well into it
bro he makes prison look way too fun
though that's the problem that's kind of
what prison is
bro I think that's what it is dude I
talked to a guy in my pod a week ago
that said if I could get laid in prison
I'd be there for the rest of my life
quote verbatim he's like everything's
awesome you hang with your boys low
security like it's just like playing
cards all day it's like the only thing
is female contact he's like it's the
only thing you there's no responsibility
to completely remove the anxiety of
personal accountability yeah I bet if
you you gave them female contact things
would be way more relaxed maybe a lot
more a lot less violence in the prison
you got to milk them maybe you just milk
them yeah oh you like line them up you
line them up line exactly ai ai I'm down
for that usage of AI just [__] hand
jobs for
prison part but then what do you do with
all of
it like all the samples that's actually
a good point cuz you don't want to put
it back out there in the world because
then you're just making more felons mhm
so yeah what do you do with it protein
shakes or something I guess you could I
guess you could put it back in a diet
maybe you can feed it to pigs or
something like that don't they eat like
weird stuff yeah I bet you put it in the
soil you grow [__]
beanock you know the porns where it's
like crazy loads of [__] and [__] like
that you know repurposes oh use it as
like a prop prop it could be prop come
or an only F
thing that actually would be kind but I
[__] with I I like it man I like it
what's the feedback been with it
positive have there been haters I mean
always some people saying this is you
know the Stanford Prison experiments
they're like this could go that way
whatever this glorifies negative
stereotypes blah blah blah but the guy
making content he's not trying to change
the world yeah yeah that's an unfair
expectation yeah also use a promo code
Schultz you get your initial deposit
matched up to $100 I mean you put in 100
you get a 100 for free so you might as
well just do it respect shout out prize
picks man